[Music]
there is this new pop-up
in miami called covid19 essentials
you know what what process it is oh it's
like forever 21 but it's coveted 19.
it's like you get masks and [ __ ] oh
i thought it was like you can get all
your essentials like your test kit
your mask your gloves [ __ ]
antibiotics i don't know about tests
but they have like like a uv light like
sterilization
or they have like these shoe cover
dispensers where like you put your foot
through it and then like it covers your
whole shoe
the week after they find a vaccine and
we're done that's what i'm saying like i
understand
like i appreciate you know i i respect
you but maybe name it differently
name it different you know because you
don't want to the flu store yeah like
protect protect the net i assume their
business plan is like eight months long
maybe
i know right they call they're calling
it a pop-up
oh that makes sense pro-tech i like that
protect that but then like so what about
all the carrots
and it's a [ __ ] shiba doggie so what
about all the karen's who are anti-mass
are they trying to burn the store down
oh yeah they're very upset oh those
[ __ ] crazy that [ __ ] are crazy
i know it's so crazy did i tell you guys
about
the karen on karen crying myself karen
we're not karen we're not caring about
crying and crying but uh
on thursday i invited jess to go hiking
with us oh my gosh
and so jess brought her dogs you're
calling her a karen just listen just
hear me out
so we're hiking right she brought her
dogs and we didn't have him on leash and
she was just running there's me
jess and gio and taika and they're
running and then when they ran
to the front there was another lady
right there
she's like excuse me are you the owner
of these dogs
[ __ ] off and then jess goes yes i am and
then i'll like oh
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is gonna go down did you
start filming they're very no they're
very polite
well i guess i am there's a bother a kid
she's like yeah my kid's kind of scared
so they put the leash on and then we
just if jess wasn't white
it would have been a different story it
would have gone viral whatever i would i
was like oh [ __ ] karen
you were like you're going crazy and
they're just talking really politely
you're like pulling out five phones
that's what you gotta do nowadays man
just in case
excuse me when you hear that oh [ __ ]
excuse me but they had like
four u's in there
if there's a y it's like a y in there xd
use me you're like oh [ __ ] dealing with
the cat regardless what the race is
you're a karen yeah damn well anyway
back to coleman 19 essentials
so they were saying that uh they
actually
sell two ounce bottles of sanitizers
for 5.99 wow two ounces it's a tiny bit
it's a little bit
that sounds like airport prices for five
bucks yeah but that's two
no and then they also have grapefruit
scented sanitizer
for nine dollars what's grapefruit and
then they have
simple face masks that go for 29.
but 29. but if you want like a
specialized mask
they uh they have like a like a black
lives matter mask for forty five dollars
oh forty five
dollars so you're benefiting off the
black lives letter that's what people
are saying it's like you are just
benefiting from this this pandemic like
it's a trend
yeah yeah and like donating that [ __ ]
please i hope it's not an asian store
owner there's like a lgbtq mass there's
just all kinds of movement masks
well the the owner's name is nadav
benimetsky oh thank god it's not asian
it went it went
it was it started middle east and then
it ended russian yeah
like polish yeah it sounds polish to me
but it's in miami right yeah that's what
i'm hearing
it is in there in miami is that the
miami airport it looks like it's an
airport it looks like an airport huh no
it's not a mall
bro i'm not gonna pay 30 something bucks
for a mask when i just wrap a t-shirt
around my face
they also have like a a uh you know like
in the malls like the kiosk like the
embroidery
place where you can like personalize
stuff are you a personalized mask
that's so sweet i want to bedazzle my
mask
you know michael jackson used to have a
sequence mask he already did the [ __ ]
face max
[ __ ] before anybody did then he's like i
can't breathe in this
do you know that's why he sounds like
that
that's him you know i saw on twitter
recently and made me laugh they were
like
um they were like wait so now my body my
choice is a republican slogan or like
they're trying to take it
really yeah because they're like my body
my abortion
like we're anti-abortion yeah and people
who are pro-abortion like no it's my
body my choice like you don't get to
choose what i get to do with my body
but now with the mass but now the master
like well it's now it's my body my
choice
i don't want to wear these that's funny
they stole the slogan
pretty much pretty much slogan stealers
damn that's a lot there's a lot of
dumbass people in this country
i didn't realize how much [ __ ] trash
we had until
like we i started traveling that's when
i was like [ __ ] dude this
there's a lot of trash here that's why i
like to watch those dumb videos just to
remind myself that there are dumb people
around i'm like oh yeah
it's funny you need to remind yourself
you live in a nice life just kidding
i mean like then then you watch the
[ __ ] the orange county hearings
of all the people like dude that [ __ ]
was comedy
i love the woman that was dude i love
the woman that was so confident like she
really thought she did something when
she was like
my breathing is like my vagina thing's
got to breathe
it's just like she just did the greatest
thing ever
she practiced this in the shower for a
week straight i'm gonna nail this
they're gonna [ __ ] oh i'm gonna nail
it it's just things need to breathe
the thing that sucks was that there was
one guy that was like a teacher he was
like
even my fifth graders i tell them that
they need oxygen
to breathe blah blah blah blah and i'm
like you need to learn about
oxygen a little bit and i ask people i'm
like so
what about doctors that wear that mask
all day long yeah almost every day
everyone in asia
a surgeon always wears men when people
try to sound really smart so they'll
throw in a bunch of big words and
numbers and they're like
well doctors live in a positive pressure
environment in a normal environment
positive pressure environment and i'm
like because
doctors usually have high-rise buildings
where the air pressure is much higher
yeah so they'll throw out all these
numbers and percentages and like the the
air the particles
don't go through 40 percent oxygen blah
blah blah and i'm like
[ __ ] dude the positive thing it's only
an ors
like not everyone's a surgeon yeah so
that's why it's like you're just trying
to throw out random facts that aren't
related but are kind of related but
they have a lot of big words at the same
people who are like masked kill people
but if they were to go to a doctor's
office and doctor's not wearing a mask
they would complain about it or if they
went to like a subway and they're like
oh no you're breathing on my sandwich
yeah
exactly seriously because they want
everyone else to abide
by their like standards and they don't
have to change yeah
yeah that's all it is they're entitled
[ __ ] inconvenience
is what they are no but then you have
the people that are like on the other
extreme
where uh there was this one tweet that i
saw of this waiter
i think i mentioned this before it feels
like deja vu but this waiter he was
wearing a mask
and then the tweet was was like talking
about the the patrons around
when they're trying to eat or like order
their food at a restaurant this is back
when
people could still sit inside the
restaurants and this
tweet was pretty much saying like how
dare you be so selfish
with that waiter's life and you don't
even give a [ __ ] about the waiter's life
but he cares about your life because
he's wearing a mess but you're not
wearing a mask and i'm like they're
about to eat what the [ __ ] do you want
them to do
kind of like this i'm like that's too
far like that's way
like that's not even being reasonable
how do you eat with the
[Laughter]
you gotta eat like this they're selling
mess with a zipper
oh that's not like a fly yeah that's
like a [ __ ] dominatrix like [ __ ]
i picture that i push the zipper like
this like a flashlight
it's like this oh my gosh there you go
there you go and this is how you eat
this don't even cover the nose either
yeah or like there's people who like
take their mask off to cough
because they don't want to cough in
their mouth oh my god what the [ __ ] or
like there's also
you don't even see there's there's
things on etsy where they're like
they're trying to get around
the the rule or whatever it's like these
are gorgeous glitter with their mesh
just like like fishnets basically oh my
gosh you can get around the mask
because you're still technically wearing
a mask but now you can breathe and it's
just like are you
[ __ ] stupid so you're just wearing
like a fishnets you know what
because technically it's a mask they
just never why am i gonna say it
what you hope they catch [ __ ] corona
yes i'm not gonna say
the fittest yeah i can't start yeah [ __ ]
it i just feel like i wish
that kovid targeted these people you
know like i wish we can do that
and somehow i didn't i'm wearing a mask
i'm wearing a mask guys
it's fine i could go in it's ridiculous
that's basically what they're doing dude
this is what they're doing right here
it's like i'm wearing a mask
yeah i mean most people are trying to
get around the room they just have their
nose out
and i'm like that's like my biggest a
lot of rainbows that is
covered they mean well but they're not
very i don't think so i think it's
because they're like oh i need one to be
in here but [ __ ] it i don't care
at la fitness next to my house um i mean
everyone you have to wear masks no
matter what but it's really hard working
out with the mask
you have to keep it on the whole time
yeah and everyone everyone's like always
popping their nose out or trying to do
something so
cause you're huffing and puffing it it's
hard yeah it's really hard especially
we're doing cardio and stuff
yeah this reminds me of the people who
were protesting gyms being closed
by doing push-ups outside the gym oh
yeah showing that you can work out
anywhere
[Laughter]
you know what i saw um i did a spartan
race in these military guys
they had gas masks on like this is
pre-covid
and then they were training to be able
to do cardio with gas masks if they need
to
oh that's cool i was like that [ __ ]
gangster dude so i'm like well if these
guys can do that
and then people used to wear the masks
that uh
withheld oxygen because they thought
that if you can
work under that you remember that what
is it called they
achieving hypoxic training which is like
low oxygen levels
and they're trying to see that they're
trying to mimic altitude training the
problem is
you only get like more hemoglobin if
you're living at altitude
not if you put that anything on on a
treadmill for 30. you just restrict
oxygen so you're just choking yourself
while you're working out
there's one that uh this one athlete
everyone's been sharing his picture
recently he was the uh like he was a
gold medalist
uh but he won wearing a mask because he
had such bad allergies
so they would he didn't want to go this
was like 2015 or something and he was
the gold medalist runner
with the mess yeah and he won with a
mask on so now his picture is being
shared
everywhere because i was like he can do
it yeah running like a [ __ ]
who knows how long you can go to the
grocery store karen for like 15 minutes
like people want to be oppressed
so [ __ ] you know i know it's a i
think it's a slippery slope that they
believe in
what they believe in is that first comes
the mask
then comes a disarmament then then comes
baby in a baby carriage
comes then comes anal probe ring and and
the government controls everything i saw
a picture of
this woman sweet she's like you will not
take my freedom it's a picture of a mask
and then gradually like a scarf over the
mask and then
whatever it is that muslim people wear
like they really think
that it starts with the mask and then
they become muslim i feel like everybody
should take a debate class
once so you learn that slippery slope
arguments are not a valid argument like
just that's like one of the biggest
things you learn but there's
a lot of idiots in this country like a
lot the day clubs in vegas are getting a
lot of [ __ ] right now too because
they're opening up their day club
like just they'll come party with us and
buy a bottle you have to wear a mask
that's made out of board short material
you can get wet look it's just like a
seashell too
yeah it's all decorated all cute it's
stupid i used to i used to wear
a uh one of my costumes go go dancing
was a
rabbit ears with a gas mask if i can
dance on
stage with that in giant stock like just
big boots and
you can you can handle a [ __ ] grocery
store run on a little paper
yeah if you could go uh
trick-or-treating for a [ __ ]
halloween costume
on halloween night [ __ ] you can wear a
[ __ ] mask
all ravers are pro editors stop
embarrassing us
americans i hate these people dude i
hate them so much
but the people that need to watch this
don't watch this no they're too busy
watching fox
share it to the people that need to
watch it guys
[Music]
you